bonjour les amis
Je suis aujourd'hui avec Maxenss, Carlito et McFly
Il a confondu ! Canular ! C'est énorme ce qui se passe !
Arrêtez ! Le pauvre Mais arrêtez ! Arrêtez..
.Oh nan nan attendez ! Pause, pause. Il y a un truc sérieux qui vient de se passer.
Vous avez troué mon jean, Le pauvre!... Noon ! Aah ! *rire*
Ok, on peut tourner ou pas ?
Les amis, aujourd'hui, tout ça pour dire qu'on est sur "Ta mère en slip
*remix improvisé de Despacito nul*
*Moment de malaise*
Regarde bien, parce que normalement quand on est là..
Non ! Non, non ! T'as pas le droit d'esquiver !
Hé ! Ça veut dire que je peux t'en mettre une, c'est la nouvelle règle.
Il y a pas de nouvelle règle.
OK. Je disais donc on est sur " Ta mère en slip".
A chaque fois que j'ferai une vidéo "Ta mère en slip" j'aurai un jeu neuf sous blister
- Tu voulais l'ouvrir Maxenss ?
- Ouais, vas-y.
- Allez, ouvre-le.
J'vous rappelle les règles c'est extrêmement simple ! On a chacun une paire de lunettes avec 2 cartes sur les lunettes...
...L'une des cartes est une personne et l'autre carte est une activité.
Il faut deviner le nom de la personne et l'adjectif qui correspond en posant des questions, par exemple :
"Suis-je un homme ou une femme ?"
Est-ce qu'on est obligé de genrer la personne ? Est-qu'on peut pas s'identifier à quelqu'un d'autre, un humain tout simplement] à quelque chose d'autre ?
AH, CA RECOMMENCE !!
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vivre une expérience hors du commun?
Et à fermer vos gueules pour qu'on puisse jouer au jeu un jour?
Oui, oui je comprends !
*chantonne* Petit moment où il ouvre le paquet. C'est un peu long, c'est vrai...
Est-ce que ça aurait pu être préparé à l'avance peut-être !
- Oh ça va !
Moi je juge moi quand je vais dans tes vidéos ?
Bon les mecs, vous êtes prêts ? [Oui oui voilà] C'est parti
*musique: What Do You Mean*
Ok les amis, à tour de rôle vous allez pouvoir poser des questions
pendant une durée limitée, pour trouver, tout d'abord, le personnage.
Quand vous avez trouvé le personnage, vous passez à l'adjectif. Alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?
[Ouais!] On va commencer par Mcfly. Attention ! TOP!
Je suis réel ? [non]
Il a jamais été aussi sérieux *rires*.
Un dessin animé ? [oui]
Je suis en 3 dimensions? Ou dessiné à la main?
En 3 dimensions
Putain, le mec il est fort !
Humoristique ?  Oui !
C'est fini. Hé mec, je crois que
j'ai jamais vu un mec aussi fort *rires*
Il pose pile les questions qu'il faut! Maxenss t'es prêt ?
- Okaay.
*rire*
TOP!
Est-ce-que c'est Johnny Hallyday ? Non ! *rires*
Est-ce que c'est Vincent Lagaffe ? Non !
est-ce-que c'est patchi de MAIS PUTAIN! *rires*
T'es fictif, t'es fictif.
Euh, Tintin ? *rires* pas loin pas loin
Est-ce que je suis un Homme ? non
Est-ce que je suis une femme ? non plus. Est-ce que je suis...C'est fini c'est fini ta gueule tu fermes ta gueule !
Il est sorti de ça avec 0 indice
T'es prêt ?
Non attends deux secondes.
Tu me dis.
J'essaie de me rappeler la fin de Friends.
Oui mais nan
Ah c'est pas le moment? -Tu veux que je te dise?
Oui nan nan d'accord ok vas-y
OK c'est parti !
Suis-je un personnage fictif ? -non
Je suis un personnage réel, qui fait de la télévision -oui
Présentateur de télé ? -oui
Le JT? -non
C'est pas le JT  c'est la météo ? -non. C'est... Euh...C'est fini c'est fini!
*musique triste*
Squezzie : Vous êtes beaucoup trop stressés , vous pouvez vous détendre.
McFly : Non, mec !
NON !
Squezzie : J'peux jouer peut être ?
McFly : Oui, pardon.
Squezzie : Très bien, c'est parti.
Je suis un homme ?  *oui*
Je fais de la télé? *hésite*
*non*
Je suis réel ? *oui* *si si tu fais de la télé*
C'est les jeunes qui me regardent *malheureusement oui*
C'est un homme ,
il fait un peu de télé malheureusement, *c'est fini* c'est un YouTubeur *si si c'est fini. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Carlito: mais il continue
Nan, nan
Regarde je peux te montrer un truc ? Ok alors j'ai fait un peu de télé
McFly: mais nan mec c'est incroyable! *rires*
Squezzie : OK, McFly, top !
McFly : Je suis un personnage en 3D quesqui on avec les 3D xdmasculin ? *oui*
Récent ? *non
Mais genre plus de 10 ans ? *le premier oui*
On l'a tous vu genre c'est un film hyper culte? *ouais ouais ouais OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS*
C'EST MÊME PLUTÔT RIGOLO *RIRE CHELOU*diabolique
Il a des pouvoirs? *il a un pouvoir nul malheureusement enfin nan il a pas de pouvoirs*
MERCI !
MERCI!! *rires*
Ok Maxenss, est-ce-que t'es prêt? *ouais c'est bon allez*
C'est parti !
Maxenss : Je vais poser des questions mais très rapidement.
Est-ce que je suis un animal ? *non*
OK, est-ce-que je suis un... *la carte tombe* *NAAN!!!!* *rires*
*rires*
McFly : C'est pas grave! Ça tourne toujours.
Carlito : oublie les lunettes vas-y on joue.
McFly : Il est tellement transpirant qu'on peut lui coller...  *rires*
Squezzie : Remettez-lui ses lunettes arrêtez arrêtez.
Carlito : On lui remet ses lunettes y a pas de soucis.
Maxenss : C'est très dégradant et humiliant au fait
Heuu donc j'suis pas un homme, j'suis pas une femme j'suis ni un animal...*si tu es un animal*
Je suis un animal inventé? *oui, non, rire*
Carlito : Qu'est-ce que tu dis ?
Squezzie: C'est pas un animal, qu'est-ce que tu raconte?
McFly : Bien sûr que si, c'est un animal.
Squezzie : Non mais ça va pas ?
McFly : Ah ouais ? Pause !
ps ma chaine youtube: mayoumie d'msp
McFly : Voilà, j'ai tellement raison.
Squezzie : Mais c'est faux !
McFly : Regarde-là, la première ligne.
"...sont des animaux"
Carlito : Excuse-moi, là t'es sur le truc littéral mais lui
tu le mets sur une fausse piste
Maxenss : Les gars, au pire, dites-moi et moi j'arbitre, je dis si c'est un animal ou pas *rires*
Squezzie : Tu sais quoi ? Tu dis le nom d'un personnage de dessin animé très connu au moment où
le temps revient à la normale t'es prêt? C'est parti.
Maxenss :Arnold *non*
Les razmoket ?
McFly : Mais pourquoi tu as que des références de 1992.
Carlito : Surtout le parti pris dans son jeu, c'est de dire les blases.
Squezzie : Bon, McFly...
OOOOHHH MY GOD!! IL VIENT DE CONFONDRE POUR DE VRAI !!
Carlito : Nan nan nan, là, ça me fait mal. Vous êtes le Palmashow?
McFly : C'est excellent j'adore votre émission
Squezzie : McFly, t'es prêt ou pas?
On y va.
Carlito : Donc je suis un présentateur homme de la télé française *oui*
Mais cette émission n'est pas un jeu? *non*
Ni un divertissement ? *si*
Arthur! *nan*
Mais c'est dans ce genre là *oui*
Est-ce-que je suis marrant?
*là dans cette salle tout le monde pense que nan* OK d'accord
et je fais gagner des sous aux gens? *nan*
*c'est fini c'est fini*
HANOUNA
J'pourrais pas le dire, j'pourrais pas le dire  *rires*
Maxenss : Dis-toi, c'est pas Guy Lux.
Carlito : Putain! À caque vanne; il perd 5ans.
Squezzie : OK, les amis, vous êtes prêt ?
*ouai vas-y!* est-ce-que je le connais? *oui probablement* il est youtubeur?
*nan* *on peux le dire*  D'UNE CERTAINE FAÇON IL EST YOUTUBEUR MAIS C'EST QUOI ÇA?!
*C'EST LE NIVEAU 0 DU JOURNALISME VOILA!!* *et il est youtubeur niveau 0 aussi*
*Squeezie.exe a cessé de fonctionner*
*ça balance pas maal à Paris*
*bisous* *renifle* et tu renifles dis donc.
Prend du stérimar *Stérimar de la qualité quand vous avez le nez qui coule*
Attends mais tu viens de faire un placement dans ma vidéo mais ça va pas t'es taré*
mais nan mais pas du tout*
et prenez du dakin pour les panari j'ai appris ça c'est David qui me l'a dis tout à l'heure
mais arrêtez de faire des placement! *j'avais un mal de tête j'ai pris du dafalgan*
MAIS ARRÊTEZ DE PLACER MAIS ÇA VA BIEN NAN OH!!
*t'es prêt?* vas-y go. Est-ce-que je suis dans l'univers marin?
*y a un peu mais non* *univers marrant(jeux de mots)*
*n'empêche que les petits plats picard quand même quand t'es en galère ça te sauve la vie*
MAIS ARRÊTEZ DE FAIRE DES PLACEMENTS!!
Alors en fait,
ça fait genre 30min que personne a trouvé de perso *moi j'ai trouvé mon perso* non *si*
OH J'TAI EU!! TU VOIS C'EST LA PSYCHOLOGIE !!! *mais enfin Mcfly il t'a eu avec une technique
de manipulation d'enfant!!* *je suis pas un enfant moi blblblblblbl*
*Ca tourne, ça tourne!* Est-ce-que je suis le héros de ma fiction?
*oui* série? *série animé oui* adulte? *nan*
STOP!!!
Aah Bob l'éponge c'est bon je l'ai hop c'est gagné *attends puisqu'il faut attendre son tour*
*carlito t'es prêt?* est-ce-que je suis Cyril Hanouna? *oui* *nan*
*tu es Cyril Hanouna sous un autre nom* ah c'est Baba *oui très bien*
Est-ce-que le contexte dans le carré droit est un lieu? *nan* ok c'est une activité? *oui*
Baba fait la vaisselle? *nan*
Baba fait du overboard? *nan*
Baba fait du curling? *nan*
Baba fait des osselets ? *nan nan *
Baba fait une paella? *nan*
Baba construit un meuble Ikéa? *nan*
Baba achète un trépied? *nan*
Baba a mis ses petites lunettes pour jouer au jeu avec ses potes *nan*
Baba s'abonne à la chaîne de Mcfly et Carlito? *OUIIIIIIIIIII*
J'ai vraiment cru que t'allais tomber dessus
Baba effectue le dab, auto-référence! *il aurait pu*
*il aurait pu* *il aurait vraiment pu* *rires*
*Oh la vache, regardez le focus. On dirait un moine
tibétain qui n'a rien d'un moine et qui n'est pas du tout tibétain.* mec j'ai aucune idée.
*Moi j'ai rien non plus* * Mais toi t'as une piste !*
T'as une piste de ski chez toi? *LA LA LA LA* (musique humoristique en fond)
*Pet de Squeezie* *Rires*
Sache que si tu le gardes pas (au montage) je viens péter dans ton studio !
C'est parti !
*Intense réflexion de squeezie*
*Oh il prend son temps* *Il a une technique !*
Est-ce que vous l'avez déjà rencontré personnellement?
Mcfly * Moi ouais mais sans plus*
Carlito * Lui ouais mais moi non et je veux pas !*
On distingue, c'est très important, l'aspect personnel, moi je le connais pas personnellement, de l'aspect artistique et c'est le vide artistiquement
Je vais même vous dire je l'ai rencontré personnellement c'est un mec hyper cool c'est juste que ce qu'il fait ça ne va pas quoi
Je tient à dire un truc aussi que..*pet de squeezie encore une fois* *rires*
Meilleure vidéo de tout le logiciel YouTube
2 pets de squeezie vous vous rendez compte *rires*
Mais MEC ! Ce sera coupé au montage ces pets de stress !
il y aura un beep sur le son du pet *rires*
un peu avant un petit peu avant
Tu vois là je me chauffe j'ai hâte d'être à la 4ème partie je pense que je serais vraiment bon
Attention parce qu'ils te les remettent mais pas trop non plus *Carlito embrasse le bras de squeezie*
Arrête, Arrête de ... Mais arrête il t'a quitté mec *tentative de toucher le bras* Arrête il t'a quitté c'est fini !
Bon on peut juste 2 secondes après on se concentre. Je suis sorti 2 ans mais tu te rappelle *en regardant mcfly* c'était avant Erica
Je suis sorti 2 ans avec l'avant-bras gauche de Squeezie...
Et il l'a quitté il en avait marre
Il lui a écrit sur Facebook "je te quitte"
Tu crois que j'ai pu faire le deuil du couple quand on t'écrit sur Facebook?
Eh ben tu lui demandes de le voir en vrai, tu fais pas un bisous comme si de rien n'était !
Tu t'es pas demandé pourquoi il avait appelé ses enfants "Avant'' et ''Bras''?
Je sais pas
Ben ouais mec refléchi !
Tu sais quoi, tu l'a énervé il rentre chez lui.
Il va sûrement chiller sur Facebook
*Carlito veut pécho l'avant bras de Maxence*
Hola allez on y va
Mcfly *Pour les enfants alors* *oui* Je suis le héros ... Nan pour adulte aussi hein*
Pixar, Walt Disney ?
C'est Dreamworks
Ok Shrek !
Ouais
Maxence est-ce que vous êtes prêt ?
Ok !
Attention top ! *Est ce que c'est Bob l'Eponge ?
Oui ! * Euh est-ce qu'il décide de changer son assurance vie ?*
Non mais il y le mot change dans l'histoire
Est-ce qu'il change son pantalon ?
Est-ce qu'il échange des cartes ?
Non mais il échange un truc
Ya une notion d'échange *Euh ça..* Ya une notion d'ECHANGE !
C'est son sperme
C'est pas loin
STOOOOOOOOOOOOOPPPPPPPP !!!
C'est une activité  mais tu vas dans un lieu *Je lui donne un indice quand même le pauvre* *Oui c'est vrai le pauvre garçon*
Nan mais après il vient me voir après la vidéo il m'engueule *Maxence pas content* * Nan mais toi ouais ouais.Tiens-toi à carreau toi*
Tu vois il me parle comme ça tu vois après la vidéo
Ferme ta gueule...
Nan mais mec tu veux quoi
On leurs laisse peut être le temps de se rabibocher
Viens on va parler...
Nan toi tu reste là et nous on vous laisse
bon
bon tous le monde s'en va !
nan mais c'est bob l'éponge qui est tombé
Non, c'est pas Bob l'Eponge...
Tu vois comment il est, il est de mauvaises foi en plus
tu veux que je te remette ta carte
oui bah remet-la
Maxence...
laisse moi
mec max max max
A chaque fois après les videos
oui à chaque fois on se prend la tête et je sais jamais pourquoi !
Dites-vous une qualité que vous pensez de l'autre, allez
Mais je peux pas il est chiant nan
allez allez les gars
nan mais après chaque videos il vient me voir est il m'engueule vous êtes pas là vous
tu ne regarde pas ne regarde pas regarde là bas et dit une qualité
Allez ! Luca ! Lucas c'est à toi
Maxence, donne-nous un compliment sur Lucas.
Lucas tu sens bon...
Ok, bon, c'est sympa déjà
Lucas à toi
Maxence...
tu as de beaux cheveux. AH ben voilà
Ok Maintenant un petit rapprochement physique
Maintenant on se rapproche, allez on se regarde au moins. Arrêtez vous me gênez Aller on se regarde  voilà
Et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Tu me feras plus ça tu me promets ?
(McFly): Eh Non! Qu'est ce que tu fait là? T... Tu... T'es gentil avec lui.
Bon ramène ton pieds là. Mais tu... Qu'est ce que tu fait
Mais arrête Maxenss. on fait pas devant les gens, t'avais dis...
Vas-y (Carlito): Voila. Allez on peut y retourner
Allez les garçons, on y va.
Oh Putain !! Comme on a changer de place, on est un peu perdu.
LOL
C'est à Carlito.
OK. Donc BABA es-ce qu'il fait quelque chose de physique?
Ouais
Ah un mouvement physique
OUI
Il fait un truc pour faire croire qu'il est jeune ?
Il fait pas l'DAB ? *bruit sonore*
OK, ben il fait pas le dab *non*
Maxenss: Nan *rire*
Baba fait un dab?
Baba fait un dab ?
OUAIS !
OUI !!!
Mcfly *musique* :
Je fais des dabs par millier je fais des dabs je fais des dabs, pardon
Mcfly : Pardon :x
C'est à moi
Squeezie : C'est à moi !
Squeezie : Est-ce qu'il à plus de 100 000 abonnés ? *Oui*
Squeezie :  Est-ce qu'il à plus de d'1M d'abonnés ?
Mcfly : Oui un peux, t'es pas loin...
Quoi ?!
Squeezie : QUOIIIIII ?!
Carlito: Il reste un grain, il fait des interviews des gens issues d'un truc précis
Squeezie: Le délire journaliste ça m'a mis sur la fausse piste direct ! *Bah oui !*
Bah oui !
Squeezie: Ah j'ai trouvé !
Squeezie: Toi t'es le pire, toi ! *Désignant Mcfly* Bob l'éponge c'est un "Animal"
Toi t'es le pire toi. Bob l'éponge c'est un "animal". JeremStar c'est un "Journaliste"
Squeezie: Jeremstar c'est un "Journaliste"
Mais arrête toi
Mcfly: Je n'ai jamais dis qu'il était...
Ah j'ai une anecdote...
Attend, ta gueule, je voudrais un maximum de commentaire sur la video
Mcfly: Je voudrais un maximum de commentaires sur la vidéo
Mcfly: Pour bob l'éponge est un animal
Pour Bob l’éponge, c'est un animal
Je veux #Boblépongeestunanimal, Team Macfly, on est la représente *Dab*
Squeezie: Ou alors pour vous, Bob l'éponge est une éponge de vaisselle
Mcfly: MAIS QUI VÎT DANS LA MER ? UNE EPONGE NE VÎT PAS DANS LA MER ! ELLE VÎT DANS UN LAVABO
Carlito: J'ai la question pour vous ! Pour essayer de *se fait couper la parole*
Ouais ben on se coupe ON SE COUPE ALORS !
Mais, ON CE COUPE ALORS ? *silence*
Carlito: Pour essayer de faire avancer le débat est-ce que vous faite partis des gens
Pour essayer de faire avancer le débat, est-ce que vous faites partie des gens qui
Qui humidifie la brosse à dent AVANT de mettre le dentifrice ?
Mcfly: Ce n'est PAS dans le débat ! *Ah oui !* C'est autre chose !
Squeezie: Est-ce qu'après avoir fait caca vous vous essuyez debout, ou assis ?
Mcfly: Mais ! Est-ce que vous faite caca dans le noir ?
Et complètement nu ?
Carlito: Est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé après avoir fait caca, à vous essuyez par devant ?
Maxenss: Est-ce que dans la douche vous vous pissez dessus parce que c'est marrant c'est un peux chaud
*Gros Blanc*
Squeezie: Tu sais quoi ? Y'a quelqu'un qui est avec nous dans cette pièce
C'est la personne qui tiens la caméra
Squeezie: Moi j'ai envie qu'il vienne ici, est qu'ils nous disent si il pense que Bob l'éponge
Et une éponge de vaisselle ou une éponge de mer ou un animal
Mcfly: On est deux contre deux la, Maxenss et avec moi
Squeezie: Toi tu pense que c'est une éponge de vaisselle ou pas ? *Carlito: Ah oui oui !*
Squeezie: On va faire venir cette personne, il s'apelle Susan Boyle, on accueille Susan Boyle
Mcfly: Susan Boyle ! *Applaudit* Bravo ! *Musique Qui veut gagnez des millions*
met toi la met toi là, met toit à la place de Carlito
Tu connait Bob l'éponge ? Oui je connait Bob l'éponge
Attention Attention Tu répond de manière simple est efficace
Selon toi Est-ce que Bob L"éponge et une éponge
De la mer donc l'animal ou une éponge qui permet de nettoyer
Les restes de ton steak haché dans ta poêle
Ou autre choses
*Moment de suspense*
Une éponge de vaiselle ?
BOOOOOOOM !
HO ! PUT1
Drop de sablier
Mes mec sa va sa va aller
Tu me touche pas tu me touche pas
Touche moi pas. Touche moi pas Squeezie: Eh non mais ça va, c'est bon là
Touche moi. Touche moi pas.
Eh les mec, c'est pas grave. Enfin, c'est un débat d'opinion.
Touches moi. Touches moi. TOUCHES... TOUCHES PAS!
Squeezie: Mais tu viens de me dire. Tu m'as dit de toucher. Il m'a dit de toucher.
C'est Incroyable. Je dis deux fois touche pas.
En vrai, il faut que j'aille pisser. Je me retiens plus.
P*tain mais mec vas pisser !
Euh..Je vous signale qu'on est seul sur la chaîne de Lucas sans Lucas. On fait ce qu'on veut.
*En chœur avec McFly* Alors abonnez-vous à la chaîne de MacFly et Carlito.
Et celle de Maxence qui est  l'étoile montante, c'est un bijoux.
On essaie de donner les maximum pour innover et pour vous plaire
*Moment émotion* Maman je t'aime.  Tiph ma femme je t'aime. 10 qu'on est ensemble , je t'aime !
Merci ! Merci encore, je vous aime.
Ok ! Maxence t'es près ? On y va !
Ok.. Il va dans... Il va dans un club échangiste.
Bonne réponse
Voilà c'est bon
Donc tu es ?
Bob l'éponge qui va dans un club échangiste. C'est bon ! Allez Allez ! Hop là !
Pourquoi tu enlèves ? J'ai gagné et je n'ai pas enlevé.
Ah oui ! C'est vrai !
En fait ça fait 45 minutes que vous faites semblant d'être nul ?
Oui un peu c'est ça.
Ok Lucas , t'es près ? Ouais ! Go !
Je suis Jeremstar. Ok ! Je fais une activité ?
Tu appartiens à un groupe.
Je suis en tournée ?
Oui !
Il faut le nom de la tournée.
Ok. C'est partie McFly !
C'est en rapport avec internet ?
ça se fait sur Internet
Un genre sur Youtube ?
Oui !
Shrek fait une postcast ? Shrek fait du Gaming ? Shrek fait une caméra cachée ? Shrek fait une dégustation ?!
Schrek fait un Vlog ? *cris de joie* OUAIS!!!
OUI!!!!
Bon vas-y on en fait une deuxième les mecs ?
*Dans un brouhaha * Ouais !!! Je suis chaud comme la braiseuh !
Est-ce qu'on va pas nous même écrire le "Ta mère" et le "En slip" ?
Donc la personne et l'activité.
Oui ! Totalement oui ! Totalement.
Vous êtes près ? Oui !
Ok ! Carlito j'écris ce qu'il y'aura sur tes lunettes.
Alright. Maxence tu écris ce qu'il y'a sur les lunettes de...
Mais c'est Mort ! On avait dit Carlito et moi !
Personne ne voulais que Maxenss écrive parce qu'il est perché et il va écrire *rire* un truc hyper chaud à trouver
Il va écrire Dalida fait du ski
On le fait ensemble Maxenss
*Musique cliché de comédie romantique*
Les amis c'est fini , nous avons tous nos lunettes
Nous sommes près ,je propose que j'ouvre le bal
*okey* *Absolument*
Je suis réel ? *oui* Je suis un homme ? *oui*
Je suis acteur ?*oui mais c'est pas ton activité principale*
Je suis chanteur ? *Oui tu l'as été et tu étais vraiment incroyable *
Ouais mais oublie ça vraiment
Je suis acteur
Mais-
*Rires* Je repose les mêmes questions
Le mec est incroyable!
Est-ce que je suis chanteur ?
Est-ce que je suis réel?
J'ai fais du théatre ?
Mais ça se passe sur scène aussi.
Okay, c'est partis
Ok. Suis-je à la téle ?
Non
Sur internet ?
Oui
J'suis un homme ou une femme ?
Un homme
Un enfant ?
Oui.
Néo ?
Ouai !
*Chante* Je suis néo !
Je fais un truc, ou je suis dans un truc ?
T'es à un truc...
Oui il se passe des choses...
C'EST FINI HE HO!
Ouh ! Il y va vite !
Okay, c'est partit.
Est ce que je suis fictif ?
Non.
Est ce que je suis un homme ?
Oui
Je suis vieux ?
Est ce que je manie les mots ?
Oui
Alain Rey ?
Oui *rire*
Est ce que je fais quelque chose ?
Oui
Est ce que c'est une activité quotidienne ?
Non
Est ce que c'est une activité what the fuck ?
Finis !
Un personnage fictif dans un film ?
Oui
Trilogie ?
Ou duologie ?
Oui duologie.
Ok je suis rocket ?
MAIS REGARDEZ ! LES MECS !
Ce matin j'arrive, ils étaient entrain de parler
Des gardiens de la galaxie !
En train de kiffer à propos de ce film.
Ah ! Bien sur ok ! I am Groot !
YEEAHHH